vous savez quand je suis arrivé où quand
j'avais 15 ans j'avais un blanc dans la
tête en disant je veux pas bref c'était
une idée fixe
[Musique]
il ya quelques jours j'ai rencontré
esther seynod à tout juste 15 ans esther
c'est noah été déportés vers le camp de
concentration et d'extermination
d'auschwitz birkenau
pendant la seconde guerre mondiale et
elle a perdu une grande partie de sa
famille dans ces camps de la mort elle
est donc l'une des rares survivantes de
ces camps et parmi les dernières
personnes à pouvoir encore témoigner
aujourd'hui
alors vous allez le voir l'histoire
d'esther seynod est à la fois unique par
son intensité ces multiples
rebondissements mais elle est aussi le
reflet le reflet d'un moment de
l'histoire par le prisme de la vie d'une
jeune fille juive en france dans les
années 40
[Musique]
espère seynod est donc né en pologne en
1928 sous le nom d'esther dit qu elle
est la sixième enfant d'une famille
juive modeste qui face à l'antisémitisme
montant en pologne va décider tout
simplement de migrer vers la france la
france étant perçue à l'époque comme le
pays des droits de l'homme
en 1930 sa famille va s'installer à
paris dans le quartier populaire de
belleville où réside une importante
communauté de juifs polonais à ce moment
là esther a donc deux ans neuf ans plus
tard lorsque la france déclarent la
guerre à l'allemagne nazie le 3
septembre 1939
esther à 11 ans en mai 1940 les
allemands envahissent la france et le 22
juin
l'armistice est signé entre la france et
l'allemagne
le mois suivant c'est le maréchal pétain
qui obtient les pleins pouvoirs et qui
devient le chef de l'état français à
france est alors divisée par une ligne
de démarcation au nord c'est la zone qui
est donc occupée par l'armée allemande
et au sud c'est la zone libre qui est
sous l'autorité du gouvernement de vichy
mener donc par le maréchal pétain
rapidement des lois qu'il limite les
libertés des juifs sont votées en france
et dans un premier temps ils doivent
tout simplement se faire recenser en
tant que juif pour que leur religion
apparaissent sur leurs papiers
d'identité sur les papiers d'identité
mais tu es un temps pour rouge où il ya
de marquer juifs dessus c'était le cas
de votre famille bien sûr parce que il
ya eu le problème maintenant on nous a
reproché d'avoir fait d'avoir été
recensement mais vous savez nous indique
est tellement respectueux et en tant
qu'étranger on était tellement
respectueux des lois françaises
de l'instance était la police française
qui nous convoquer on a fait confiance
dans les mois qui suivent il ya donc
plusieurs lois qui vont être votés à
notamment l'interdiction pour les juifs
d'exercer certains métiers
l'obligation de porter l'étoile jaune
l'obligation de ne voyager que dans la
dernière rame de métro ou encore
l'interdiction de fréquenter les parcs
les cinémas les théâtres ou encore les
bibliothèques
c'est en mai 1941 qu'a lieu un tournant
avec la rafle du billet vert la rafle du
billet vert cédant fait la première
arrestation massive de juifs à paris
suite à laquelle tu côté d'esther et
bien de l'un de ses frères est déporté
après avoir été convoqué au commissariat
et les mois suivants et bien les rafles
vont se multiplier dans le pays jusqu'au
16 juillet 1942 jour de la rafle du vel
d'hiv
a paris quelque temps
donc il ya des bruits qui couraient dans
le quartier qui devait avoir des rafles
alors là évidemment arriver le siège
sujet au matin il ya eu un grand
branle-bas longtemps budget décrit et
finalement on a entendu monter dans les
escaliers menant tambour frapper aux
portes
alors il ya des gens qui voulaient pas
ouvrir un défoncé les portes à coups de
matraque en ce sens préparé un peuvent
préparer un petit bagage que vous vous
rassemblez un bambin dans la rue alors
esther va assister avec le reste de sa
famille à l'arrestation de leurs voisins
arrêté parce que juif sans vraiment
comprendre ce qu'il se passe et une fois
le calme revenu dans le quartier et la
police et ont visiblement oublié
d'arrêter la famille d'esther et bien sa
mère très inquiètes va demander à lyster
et à sa soeur fanny d'aller chacune voir
si leurs proches sont bien en sécurité
dans le reste de paris esther va donc
partir seul de belleville vers la place
de la république où habite là-bas donc
sa belle soeur et son neveu qui
heureusement n'ont pas été arrêtés mais
le lendemain matin en rentrant chez elle
esther découvre que son appartement et
vie
mis sous scellés elle ne peut donc pas y
entrer sa famille n'est plus présente
elle sonne alors ils sont venus se
rendre compte encore mystérieux qu'ils
avaient oublié de passer chez nous et
dans ce laps de temps où je suis parti
avec ma soeur donc ils sont venus
arrêter mes parents mon petit frère
cadet montant entre le 16 et le 17
juillet 1942 la police française sur
ordre des autorités allemandes va donc
arrêter plus de 13000 juifs à bari dont
plus de 4000 enfants la plupart sont
emmenés au vélodrome d'hiver avant
d'être déportés vers le camp d'auschwitz
où la majorité d'entre eux sera
exterminé après l'arrestation de sa
famille esther va tenter de retourner
place de la république pour retrouver sa
belle soeur or entre temps et bien sa
belle soeur s'est enfui à 14 ans esther
est donc seul à paris et désespérée elle
va expliquer sa situation à la gardienne
de l'immeuble qui décide de l'héberger
pour quelques jours alors finalement
elle m'a fait rentrer dans sa loge et
elle m'a gardé une quinzaine de jure
alors vous savez en prenant des risques
parce qu'à l'époque gajan qui essayait
de sauver des juifs risque elle se faire
arrêter
savait il y avait deux france ce qui est
des circuits de lens
la gardienne réussit finalement à
trouver un passeur qui est sensé et d
esther a traversé la mise démarcation
pour rejoindre son frère à pau dans le
sud en zone libre
leicester va donc prendre le train la
boule au ventre par crainte d'être
repérés et une fois arrivé à bordeaux
est bien le passeur va finalement
l'abandonner elle décide alors de passer
seul l'est
de démarcation en traversant en pleine
nuit la forêt des landes
est ce donc pas regret l'importante
présence militaire j'ai attendu vers
10h30 commençait à faire nuit
je suis sorti puis vous savez à 14h on
court vite alors j'ai réussi à rentrer
dans cette forêt où j'ai effectivement
trouvé cette ligne de chemin de fer et
j'ai commencé à manger pendant des
heures et puis quand il a commencé à
faire nuit noire vous savez j'ai
commencé à paniquer maintenant là
j'étais complètement paniqué je tourne
en rond j'avais l'impression qu'ils les
bruits se répercute et puis vous savez
quand nous notre littérature quand on
était à paris c'était des livres contes
et légendes un canton était perdu dans
une forêt risquent de se faire dévorer
pas des bêtes fauves ou savent tous que
ne possède pas la tête quand vous êtes
complètement paniqué et juste tourner en
rond comme ça toute la nuit le lendemain
matin après plus de 48 heures sans
manger esther réalise finalement qu'elle
a réussi à passer en zone libre
elle rejoint donc son frère à pau avec
qui elle va rester quelques mois jusqu'à
la fin de l'année 1942 il en novembre
1942 en fait le frère d'esther va
s'engager dans les forces françaises
libres donc des unités formées par le
général de gaulle pour combattre le
régime autoritaire de vichy en france
esther va alors décider de rentrer à
paris dans l'espoir de retrouver sa
famille mais malheureusement quand elle
arrive à paris
elle réalise que sa famille n'est
toujours pas présente
les mois suivants esther doit donc se
débrouiller seul dans la capitale
jusqu'à un soir d'août 1943 ou en
sortant du métro saint paul trois
policiers lui demandent ses papiers
esther refuse d'abord de leur donner son
adresse et son monde qui a une
consonance étrangère et les policiers
l'emmènent alors au commissariat
et puis au bout d'un moment à force
d'être eu un peu secoué violemment
j'ai fini par donner mon nom avec le
recensement les policiers constatent qu
esthétique et juive
et dès le lendemain elle est conduite à
drancy un camp de transit dans lequel
les juifs sont enfermés quelques jours
avant d'être déportés qu'est ce que vous
ressentez à ce moment là c'est de la
peur j'imagine dont sap en haïti la
porte ont été un soulagement parce que
doute aux 38 c'était de se faire arrêter
alors finalement moi ça a été un
soulagement disant versailles et j'ai
fini trenet la galère je vais retrouver
mes parents pour moi ça a été un
soulagement après son arrestation esther
va passer quelques jours à à drancy où
elle rencontre marie une jeune femme qui
a cinquante plus qu'elle c'est le début
à ce moment là entre esther et marriage
d'amitié et de deux destins liés à
jamais quelques jours plus tard le 2
septembre 1943 un millier de juifs dont
esther et son amie marie sont amenés
depuis drancy vers la gare de bobigny où
stationnent sur place des trains à
bestiaux
quand on a vu ce train d'une longueur
ont pas suivi ce drapeau est pour nous
un ceux des wagons à bestiaux et
instruments un autre train qui va venir
ballon c'était pour nous maintenant là
et ils nous ont propulsés dans ces
wagons ce jour-là esther est emmené vers
le camp d'auschwitz-birkenau en pologne
par le 59e convoi de ce type
un convoi d'ailleurs dont elle et son
ami
marie seront les deux seules femmes à
survivre au camp dans ce voyage vous
l'imaginez les conditions sont
absolument terribles
et puis dans les wagons à bestiaux y
avait juste une petite lucarne grillage
sûrs il y avait pas d'air alors ils nous
ont mis un soin et de l'eau ils nous ont
mis un tonneau pour les deux religions
ni qu ils ont fermé les portes ils ont
verrouillé les portes du train parti
alors évidemment vous dire raconter ce
qui s'est passé dans cette main pendant
trois jours alors le premier jour
évidemment il ya huit ou six personnages
et qui tombait par terre en ont
évidemment eu peur on se retire encore
davantage pour laisser de la place
marque 10-6 asseoir les bébés qui
commence à hurler enfin les enfants qui
ornait ça a été quelque chose
d'effroyable une nuit effroyable et le
lendemain évidemment le premier c'est le
premier jour des soldes a été vidée en
solo parce qu'on avait soif
et puis la deuxième nuit là le noeud
tout doux pour livraison en août s'est
renversé dans la fille du voyage là
dedans dont vous rêvez que tant qu'elle
est en doute arriver quand le train
s'est arrêté après trois jours de voyage
sans fin le train s'arrête le 4
septembre 1943
esther est donc arrivé au camp
d'auschwitz birkenau
c'est à la fois un camp de concentration
donc un camp de travail mais aussi un
camp d'extermination
c'est à dire donc un camp destiné à tuer
massivement les personnes qui sont
présents
avant d'entrer dans le camp les soldats
allemands on demande aux personnes âgées
aux enfants et aux femmes fatiguées de
monter dans des camions
et puis ils font défiler les personnes
restantes une par une et les sépare en
deux files 106 femmes dont esther seynod
et marie sont à leurs sélectionnés pour
rentrer travailler au camp et quand on
est arrivé devant la porte d'entrée qui
s'est ouverte avec avez vous voyez rien
y avait une fumée épaisse
puis des odeurs qu'on n'arrivait pas à
définir alors on a commencé à marcher
pour entrer dans le camp et puis là on a
vu le long de l'allée principale des
cadavres dans des coteaux qui deux côtés
de loi envoyait des chiens avec les
capots qui courait après ddd des femmes
qui était dit squelette ambulant
alors on se demandait dans quel enfer on
était rentrés et effectivement on voyait
donc ces espèces de fumée qui sortait
alors comme on en avait parlé d'un camp
de travail je sais pas si c'est
peut-être un truc industriel enfin vous
savez on savait pas du tout on était on
a fini par leur demander mais les
personnes qui sont dans les camions
quand est ce qu'on va les retrouver
alors nous ont dit on va vous faites pas
d'illusions les fumées vous voyez c'est
pas 2 c'est pas des trucs est
industrielle ciri chambres à gaz
alors qu'ils sont mauvaises on n'avait
jamais entendu parler seul encore moins
deux fours crématoires
alors alors on dit mais c'est pas
possible que c'est que ce truc là alors
finalement paris on s'est dérobé devant
répondre ça pour nous faire peur c'est
pas possible comment voulez-vous deux
heures après notre arrivée que j'ai pu
tuer 650 personnes comme ça en si peu de
temps je croyais pas très vite
esther est entièrement rasé et on va lui
trouver un numéro
numéro 5 8 3 1 9 directement sur le bras
on a écrasé entièrement et ensuite on a
été tatoué sur le bras nous sont à toi
numéro en disant que maintenant nous
n'avions plus d'identité dans l'instant
était interpellé dans le camp il fallait
donner notre numéro un en avant
évidemment quand vous parlez pas
l'allemand 1 sera clair numéro 5
chiffres c'est pas évident et après
quelques jours esther comprend que très
peu sortiront vivants de ce camp pas
vous souvenez quand je suis arrivé où
quand j'avais 15 ans j'avais un blanc
dans la tête orbison je veux pas mourir
seul site est unique et fixons à
auschwitz-birkenau les comptes de son
fils sont terribles
chaque matin un appel a lieu pour
décompter les décès qui sont 1 survenu
dans la nuit
cet appel dure parfois des heures les
corps sont donc alignés devant les
baraques où les déportés dorment temps
passé sur des planches chaque soir et
après l'appel le matin esther doit
travailler de force des travaux
difficilement supportable est
complètement inhumain et en fin de
journée les déportés doivent
quotidiennement se plier à une sélection
pendant laquelle les nazis sépare d'un
côté et personnes qu'ils considèrent
comme encore apte à travailler et de
l'autre côté les personnes jugées
trop faible et qui sont donc envoyés
directement vers les fours crématoires
il y avait toujours ses deux fils et
puis ce sera 10 parce que là je cite la
file de droite que temps voyait chromate
au lendemain c'est la file de gauche
vous savez on a toujours l'angoissé
quand on veut nos candidates en
calculant va être dans le camp les
déportés ne sont quasiment pas nourri
elle partage en fait une gamelle dans
laquelle les chefs des blocs servent de
la soupe qu'elles doivent manger sans
cuillère de loin on voyait les capots
enfin tout le personnel qui avaient des
fonctions dans le camp en train de
ricaner devons regarder on vous avait
dit que juste c'était pas des êtres
humains vers l'iss comportent comme des
chiens elle avait encore quand il y
avait encore un peu de soupe dans le
fond de doutes nous allons renverser par
terre vous avez des centaines de femmes
qui se couchait partout essayer de
récupérer quelque chose en dehors des
travaux forcés dans des petites lycée
vie ce qu'on pouvait subir elle faisait
exprès de douze décès du 10è 10
immunisés depuis ce possible enfin ça a
été une période épouvantable
je vous serais tellement de choses qu'on
peut pas raconter parce que nous mais
vous savez quand tu penses matin vous
dit c'est pas possible qu'ils aient pu
fuir les expériences qu'ils ont fait sur
légion un soir de l'hiver 1943 alors
questerre est aux latrines une jeune
femme l'interpellent et cette jeune
femme et bien c'est sa soeur aînée fanny
moi je porte aux nues c'est elle qui m'a
reconnu quand elle m'a vu les bus vers
malmö lorsqu'il paire de claques
non mais disons
je suis content je pensais que toi au
moins tu aurais réchapper elle n'a pas
voulu comprendre depuis après évidemment
elle m'a pris dans ses bras étaient de
retrouvailles est on ne peut plus
pénible valmy qui était arrivé au camp
dix mois plus tôt et donc déjà très
faible et son état ne fait qu'empirer
ces quelques mois plus tard en mars ou
en avril 1944
questerre parle pour la dernière fois
avec sa soeur dans leur offrir un
baraquement destiné aux prisonniers
malades
ma soeur était couché dans leur vie
alors je suis du fan tu peux pas rester
là tu te rends compte que c'est très
bien ce qui va arriver à beaucoup de
gens plus pluvieux c'est fini elle dit
la sauce ou ce que je regrette c'est de
ne pas être monté dans les camions en
arrivant parce que le déficit cas
jusqu'au bout et ses fils soient
tranquilles
j'en peux plus c'est fini pour moi et là
c'est là qu'elle m'a pris dans ses bras
quelle bague écoute toi tu es jeune
encore tu as l'air de tenir le coup la
guerre va bientôt finir 17e car les
coûts le plus longtemps possible
si tu as une chance de revenir premiers
mois de raconter ce qu est ce qui vous
est arrivé qu'on soit pas les onglets
d'histoire et puis finalement après il a
fallu qu est ce que je vaux près de les
rangs pour aller travailler
quand surfer bull fin était plus là le
18 janvier 1945 alors que l'allemagne
nazie est au bord de la défaite
militaire et que les troupes aux russes
s'approche d'auschwitz le camp et évacué
et les prisonniers très affaibli sont
transférées durant des jours à pied et
dans un froid glacial vers d'autres
camps cette marche c'est ce que l'on
appelle les marches de la mort si toutes
les mains vides qui sortent des rangs
qui s'écroule est le seul avec son
pistolet était une balle dans la nuque
nous savons à l'issue du mandat sur le
bord de la route et après plusieurs
jours de marche
esther et mari arrivent d'abord en
allemagne dans le camp de concentration
de bergen-belsen
et alors là les baraques était une barre
à quitter grande ouverte aux clubs de
cadenas dans des mêmes jusque devant les
portes
impossible de rentrer dans les baraques
un cimetière à ciel ouvert
après bergen belsen esther transitent
par plusieurs camps jusqu'à celui de
mauthausen en autriche est sur place et
bien rester à tout simplement à bout de
forces
son état de santé est en fait
catastrophique elle ne pèse plus que 32
kg et à la au delà de ça le typhus une
maladie infectieuse très très grave et
gestion 1945 j'étais toujours avec marie
on sait jamais cliqué et le 7 mai 1945
on a eu l'appel du matin la juge
anne-marie écouteurs laissera tranquille
chez certains l'appellent je ne pouvais
plus j'étais vraiment arriver au bout du
rouleau parce que dans mon esprit je me
suis dit va encore trouver un train où
ils vont nous fusiller parce que là on
sentait vraiment que c'était fini il y
avait c'était vraiment la fin de la
guerre je suis bien c'est terminé j'en
peux plus j'ai ce pas tranquille elle
m'a sorti de force à l'appel
donc on a eu l'appel ça a été vite faire
et qu'on est retenu dans les baraques et
puis elle donne en début d'après-midi en
est ressorti dans la cour on a vu le
drapeau blanc sur la forteresse du camp
et on a vu des 100 des premiers
prisonniers ils savaient que leur pyjama
rayé qui descendait en courant vers nos
baraques en nous disant a un côté les
allemands ouvrir les portes
ils ont dit qu'ils allaient revenir que
les années tuer tout le monde ne restez
pas dans les baraques
partez parce que quand il veut en venir
ils vont faire un massacre
alors il dit dont 120 si vous voulez
vous nous suiviez on vous attend pas
donc ça fait dans les temps et à moi le
battage mois déjà pu me lever et mari el
mehdi qu'est ce qu'on fait je suis moi
qui c'est du flash mob ou alors on sait
consulter avec une dizaine de femmes
qu'on était encore dans mes temps
honnête homme enfin on tenait quand même
un peu sur nos jambes et on a décidé de
sortir mon et par qui après plusieurs
rebondissements esther et marie sont
finalement rapatrié en france le 25 mai
1945 par un avion militaire américain
elles sont amenés directement à l'hôtel
lutetia à paris où les déportés sont
accueillis et où les familles affluent
dans l'espoir de retrouver leurs proches
malheureusement personne ne viendra
récupérer à ce moment-là esther après la
guerre esther a beaucoup de difficultés
à revenir à une vie normale et ce
pendant de très nombreuses années
elle dort sur le sol car elle n'arrive
plus à dormir dans un lit et au delà de
ça elle fait notamment des cauchemars en
permanence et par ailleurs comme
beaucoup de déportés esther va vraiment
souffrir de la difficulté à raconter ce
qu'elle a vécu dans les camps
alors finalement unis les gens sont
arrivés vers nous un but noble qu'est ce
que vous était arrivé
on a commencé à vouloir raconter ce qui
lui est arrivé et nous regarder en
disant mais vise est devenue folle
commente afrique vous propagez des
histoires pareilles c'est pas vrai c'est
n'importe quoi enfin bref
et puis finalement il y en a je me
souviens un monsieur qui m'a dit mais
vous êtes revenu si peu nombreux qu'est
ce que vous avez fait vous pour venir et
par les autres alors finalement on a
pratiquement été culpabilisés de des
survivants finalement après des années
très très difficile une tentative de
suicide et un séjour de quelques mois
dans un hôpital psychiatrique
esther réussit finalement à trouver un
travail et à reconstruire
étape par étape petit à petit sa vie
aujourd'hui alors questerre seynod est
âgé de 93 ans elle continue à témoigner
régulièrement et ce pour que les jeunes
générations n'oublient pas cette période
sombre de l'histoire
votre courage il est évidemment dans
cette période pendant la guerre est ce
que vous avez vécu et la façon dont vous
emmener de sortie évidemment votre
courage il est ici mais les autres quoi
je trouve qu'il est aussi dans le fait
d'en parler encore aujourd'hui et d'en
parler malgré les traumatismes
malgré ce que vous avez vécu pourquoi
est-ce que c'est aussi important pour
vous
d'en parler aujourd'hui j'avais toujours
la promesse de madonna s'agit de voir
l'indifférence savez ce qui m'a été le
plus fidèle ça a été l'un différence de
gens comme s'il n'avait jamais existé
finalement ma l'impression qu'on me
dérangeait
[Musique]
et je trouve que c'est plus difficile à
supporter us après un entretien de près
de deux heures j'ai demandé à exercer
nos c'est là vers message à faire passer
aux personnes qui regarderont cette
vidéo je vous laisse découvrir sa
réponse la chance qu'ils ont c'est de
vivre dans un pays libre et démocratique
et qu'ils fassent tout leur possible vu
les événements actuels de processus de
commande iront de protéger cette
démocratie parce que et démocratie c'est
très fragile dans les conditions
actuelles comme on est parce que
finalement entre la démocratie et la
dictature la dictature semaine à
auschwitz
[Musique]
en tout cas c'était pour moi un réel
honneur de pouvoir échanger avec esther
seynod elle vient d'ailleurs de publier
un livre qui fait le récit justement de
son histoire avec l'aide de
l'historienne isabelle ernaux son livre
s'appelle la petite-fille du passage
ronces
il est publié aux éditions grasset donc
ça vous intéresse évidemment je vous le
recommande
et je vous mets le lien a directement en
descriptions et enfin juste un petit mot
pour vous remercier parce que vous êtes
de plus en plus nombreux à suivre cette
nouvelle chaîne principale hugo décrypte
et ce alors que c'est seulement la
quatrième vidéo sur la chaîne on
approche déjà des 200 milles abonnés du
coup je ne sais pas encore le cas de
votre côté n'hésitez pas à vous abonner
pour ne pas louper les vidéos suivantes
pourquoi pas aussi à activer les
notifications pour nous soutenir et nous
encourager à continuer ce travail
gratuit directement sur youtube
écoutez je crois j'ai tout dis prenez
soin de vous présente vos proches et on
se dit du coup à très vite pour une
nouvelle vidéo
[Musique]